The next question comes from Mark Sanders.
Mark pointed out that regular expressions are very powerful and they are a useful tool,
but they can quickly become really long and hard to read.
He wants to know are there tools
that we can use online that maybe would help us generate these longer regular expressions,
and if there are, would they be useful?
So there's a lot you can do with regular expressions,
and I've seen regular expressions that are 2 or 3 lines
of just non-stop characters and special symbols and whatnot.
And at that point I have to say it's usually more useful
that you break it up into smaller regular expressions
that you connect together with code.
There's not a whole lot of value, and it's very hard to debug
regular expressions that are really long
and do your entire program in one go.
But there are tools that help you generate,
but more importantly check, your regular expressions.
There are tools that you just give it text, and you type in your regular expression,
and it will highlight everything in that text that it matches.
That's really useful for creating great expressions.
I highly recommend them if you can find them. >>Okay, thank you.